welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is going to be my reaction
to the trailer for Ant-Man of the WASP
Quantum media my in-depth frame by frame
breakdown of all the Easter eggs will
come tomorrow and my breakdown of
Jonathan Majors photo shoot is coming uh
well that's just for me for academic
reasons um anyway Let's uh react to this
trailer and afterward I'll give my
initial thoughts on the big highlights
and big moments we
let's go
oh questions
makes sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing
thank you a spider
spider I love that actor so much that's
why we made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Guana wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
oh turn it off
now
so there's some similarities with the
Comic-Con trailer in the d23 trailer but
they're leaving a lot out so far making
me think they're gonna put new stuff
that we haven't seen in there
oh interesting like
Church uh
uh chord version of this
oh wow this is reminding me a lot of
Loki right like we're seeing some
bizarre Landscapes it's super surreal it
looks awesome
my favorite Universe beneath ours looks
like a brandy snap
foreign
there's something I never told you
this is all new oh he's got an army
oh this looks amazing
oh wow the characters look so cute
and give you more time
what is that you can help me
so
What's it gonna be
yes
King is a conqueror
oh this movie's going to rock this one
is going to be so much fun to break down
and again my Easter egg breakdown is
going to come out tomorrow I'm really
gonna need some time to go through frame
by frame through all these uh new
visuals these insane Quantum real
Landscapes this civilization and this
Empire that Kang has built down there
now look at my hair it looks healthy
right like healthy enough that you might
be thinking hang on Eric did you send
your hair to a spot for a weekend
getaway well the answer is no I did not
my hair is healthy thanks to geology I
know you're all thinking geology isn't
that the 13 times award-winning skin
care company with over 5 000 5 Star
reviews well yes they are but now they
also do hair and I'm super excited about
it geology has a new custom control hair
care line with brand new co-wash co-wash
is the anti-shampoo shampoo strips your
hair of the essential oils the scalp
produces and can leave your hair drying
or scalp dry too typical shampoos use
harsh chemicals to clean your hair but
co-wash uses friction and scrubbing
motion to remove the dirt and grime from
your scalp keeping your hair clean and
healthy without damaging it in the
process because good air comes from
having a healthy scalp co-wash focuses
on cleansing and nourishing the scalp
removing the buildup and cleansing the
hair without big lather harsh
ingredients or stripping the hair of its
natural oils co-wash puts you 100 in
control if you're clean based on how
much product you use how long you use it
and how often you apply it I think it's
co-wash as you skin care for your scalp
and your hair because ultimately Hair
Care is skincare geology hair products
are great for all hair types and are
color safe and you can either get a
cooling co-wash with tea tree and aloe
or a smoothing co-wash with avocado and
coconut I'm a tea tree and aloe kind of
guy why because you can never be too
cool to celebrate the launch of their
new product they are hooking you up with
this unbelievable special offer click
the link below to get 70 off a skincare
trial but not only that use the second
link to take an additional 15 off the
new co-wash which is already 15 off for
the pre-order you're not gonna want to
miss this offer and to be clear clear
this is Kang the Conqueror who's an
alternate timeline variant of he who
remains who we saw in Loki they are
different characters so that's why you
can already tell John of the majors is
doing a completely different performance
for this version of Kang than what we
saw in Loki that variant of Kang was uh
more of like a Shakespearean Puck
trickster one who liked to jump on
furniture and giggle this gang is King
he's a conqueror he's smug he's detached
he's bitter now the question is what
does he need Scott Lang's help with now
the d23 footage went into a bit more
detail here he says that he needs help
finding something that was taken from
him he also told Scott you're an Avenger
haven't I killed you before which tells
us that this Kang in other timelines has
completely murdered all the Avengers
this guy is vicious but the fact that it
needs Scott's help we're covering
something that was taken from him tells
us that this is going to be in some ways
a heist movie in the same way that the
first two Ant-Man movies were and though
this trailer doesn't seem to show it the
answer to where this stolen thing is is
in time we're looking at another Time
Heist just one that's gonna look pretty
different to what we saw in Avengers
endgame and we have to talk about the
song choice because it is perfect Elton
John's Goodbye Yellow Brick Road uh
semi-autobiographical song about Elton
John wishing that he could return back
to his days before his stardom where he
could just go back to his home it's
using the extended metaphor of Dorothy
in The Wizard of Oz which has been a
crazy recurring thing in the MCU right
now we just had werewolf by night that
ended with Judy Garland singing
Somewhere Over the Rainbow as things
shifted into Technicolor and Elsa
Bloodstone was kind of a Dorothy figure
in that story and then in Loki he
remains this King variant presented
himself as a literal man behind the
curtain he was a wizard of odds using
his robotic puppets making people walk
down this long aisle to finally greet
him down in the void it looks like there
was an Emerald City and that was the
facade he was hiding behind and when the
heroes met him they realized he was kind
of a con man who Used Machinery there
was more science and engineering than
Wizardry to Kang's magic and that's one
thing I really liked about he who
remains that seems to be the case here
Kang does seem to have some sort of
superpowers but a lot of his power hour
seems rooted in engineering he's just a
scientist from the 31st Century he
doesn't have any godly power beyond that
he's just a you know a million steps
ahead of us so this plot is going to
involve the whole Ant-Man family right
so we have Scott Lang we have hope they
have died we have Cassie Lang his
daughter a bit older than when we saw
her before uh actually recast to the
actress who played her in Avengers end
game now played by Catherine Newton
she's going to be a member of the Young
Avengers because as Cassie Lang she
becomes stature kind of a resizing hero
in her own right she has invented this
way to communicate with a Quantum realm
something that she worked on during the
blip and I really love this idea because
my assumption was that Cassie always
thought her dad Dustin along with hope
and Hank and Janet but no Cassie was
able to arrive to that Rooftop in the
quantum realm van and conclude from that
no my dad didn't dust he's just stuck in
the quantum realm so she always held on
to that hope for that five years but not
now hold on to that hope this hope now
this trailer has given us a close-up
look of what we saw in 2018's Ant-Man
the WASP where there was a Quantum realm
City in the background of the quantum
realm and now we're seeing the full
civilization and it seems multifaceted
we have some sakharan style Warriors who
greet them on the outskirts of the city
we see that Kang has a freaking Army and
a fleet that he has built down here we
see other levels of society like Bill
Murray playing what we assume is some
kind of leader based off of his finery
from the Comic-Con and I believe the d23
footage we know that he has a history
with Janet Van Dyne they used to know
each other now something not shown in
this trailer but it was shown both of
the Comic-Con and the d23 trailer so
it's no secret but some version of Modoc
is going to be in this movie we saw a
mechanized robot face he's not in this
trailer I think probably because they
still want to figure out exactly what
the look will be with the VFX and the
post-production and maybe it's just
really hard to pick this character and
let YouTube sluice live with it forever
and ever so we can decode everything
about this character and reveal big
parts of the plot which I think honestly
is a good way to go everyone will go
into this movie knowing that Modoc will
be in it but we don't know exactly what
form Modoc will take and where exactly
he's coming from so again Kang is
conscripting Scott Lang to steal
something for him from the past or from
the future Somewhere in Time and I'm
guessing that the way this Time Heist is
going to look it's gonna be a bit more
surreal in comic bookie which I really
love like we get this one really trippy
shot of Scott Lang looking up at a
larger I think version of himself or a
different Ant-Man and this Ant-Man
unravels leaving the helmet to fall onto
him unravels the way that Thanos with
the reality Stone unravels mantis turns
into this ribbony structure it's also
not unlike the way Scarlet Witch
unraveled Reed Richards and there's
another character sitting at the cafe
who has like a semi-unraveled head there
may be some kind of like thematic thing
going on like that is the way the sacred
timeline is all coiled together right
it's a it's a tightly wound coil of
endless Loops that are all woven
together and what Sylvie did when she
stabbed Kang was basically break open
and unravel all that time so that time
kind of spread out in like a lightning
bolt configuration a spider web this
could just be what it looks like when
you use Kang's technology and you prune
something or erase something from time
it like literally unravels into ribbons
all the timeline elements that kept it
bound together are no longer have that
gravity another thing I want to point
out about King's technology I can't wait
to dig deeper into it all seems to be
powered by this kind of like glowing
sphere at about 125 he places that into
like a central console with crystals on
either side and a similar sphere seems
to occupy not just every ship every
fighter craft that's in the fleet but
literally every single soldier like
remember Kang is an engineer who likes
to build robots and stuff most of the
EBA was Androids and AI that was running
that Clockwork and this could be an army
that he built in order to conquer these
civilizations down in the quantum realm
okay I love this trailer so much I can't
wait to go back through it frame by
frame to find all the stuff that we
missed my Easter egg breakdown is coming
to the channel tomorrow you can follow
me on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at
box follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]